this is a full circle moment for
president biden he was the chair of the
judiciary committee when the senate
confirmed justice breyer in 1994. now
he'll rely on the democrats razor thin
majority to confirm a nominee before the
midterms in the fall weeja jaing is at
the white house luigi good morning good
morning to you nate and good morning to
everybody democrats want to move quickly
to shore up support for justice breyer's
replacement senate majority leader chuck
schumer says that the nominee will
receive a prompt hearing before the full
senate confirms the person with all
deliberate speed possibly similar to the
record pace that justice amy coney
barrett was confirmed just over a month
after she was nominated republicans
would like to move slower but they
essentially paved the way for a
confirmation for president biden's pick
gop lawmakers changed the senate rules
back in 2017 to allow a supreme court
nominee to be confirmed with a simple
majority and since there is a 50-50
split in the senate
as long as democrats stick together vice
president kamala harris would be able to
break the tie now with the president's
approval rating at an all-time low over
inflation and his stalled build back
better plan appointing a black woman to
the supreme court would be a campaign
promise kept and a much needed political
win asked if vice president kamala
harris was under consideration for the
supreme court white house press
secretary jen saki said that president
biden has every intention of running for
re-election in 2024 with her on the
ticket gail
all right thank you very much